whoa he's everywhere first we can tell
had dropped him 100 stories were you
able to ID the Vic yeah her Weaver worth
billions capital B what do you think mr.
Allen you see the impact on the ceiling
in the repeated lateral stress fissures
on the frame this guy didn't just drop
he was shaken to death excuse me coming
through CCPD tech consultant that's
right look at the badge that means it's
official he's aware that badge is
plastic fellas so sorry I'm late the
curls we're not cooperating this one
thing oh good lord
why would you show me that we think this
is because of some weird technical
glitch in your weird tech expert it's
completely ruined sriracha for me I
[Music]
shouldn't be there what is it it's
encrypted code
[Music]
this wasn't a glitch this was a hacker
and episode 402 mixed signals berry
coming out of speedforce used like this
new here I was thinking you need a
jumpstart for your Luka brain no brain
good Ella means good all the pain and
and trauma and damages that have
happened to him in his life that he was
Karen on his shoulders sort of gone away
he left that all in the speedforce Oh
honestly babe I'm gonna be too tired to
eat out after our evening training
session I cancelled that yeah don't
worry about that what he isn't taking
into account is that the team dynamic
has changed in his absence
Barry you can't go down that road what
why because they started construction on
that Street three months ago he's kind
of making decisions on his own and it's
causing a little rift between he and
iris and Caitlin notices this and
suggests to iris that perhaps couples
therapy would be helpful it was therapy
couples therapy meanwhile the team is
dealing with a new metahuman and kilgore
our killer isn't just hacking machines
he's controlling them our hackers not
hacker
he's a meta that's probably the worst
villain that Barry could encounter since
Cisco decided to upgrade his new suit
with a buttload of technology frak me
he's locked me out of my own programming
this is really where you know we fully
embrace the new tone for the season we
get back to the season one
lightheartedness how much tech did you
put in this suit so much
hi iris hi Barry hello hi I'm dr. Sharon
Finkel I am so sorry I kept you waiting
no no it's fine thank you for squeezing
us in oh well you made it sound so
urgent on the phone
oh no not urgent I'm excited to dive in
right oh absolutely I love therapy
Oh have you been before just once when I
was a kid after my mom died
Oh your mom but I'm okay with that I
mean I'm not okay with it obviously I
might have preferred that she was alive
I just meant that I've already dealt
with it I don't think it's worth writing
down these knows her just for me no one
is judging you guys yes you know yeah
well my dad died too just four nuts
so Barry iris filled me in a little bit
about the two of you on the phone before
getting married yeah it's been a long
road getting here first um uh growing up
together and then I was engaged to
someone else
okay that's worth a write down he's
actually tattoo you two have had to deal
with a lot of trauma well no I'm not uh
Eddie and Ronnie I mean a little my mom
a charm
not too much Laurel so I'm sorry we've
been to a few you know yeah hey
everybody new episode of the flash
tonight let's break it down and there is
a new round of that Justice League
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video I'll name a winner at the
end of this - but as they said they're
bringing the villain Kilgore from the
comics he debuted in flash volume 2
number 3 and when you look at him he
looks a little bit more like a
traditional Superman villain because he
comes from outer space he's like an
alien artificial intelligence
Brainiac style that hijacks earth
technology to live and after the flash
defeated him in this issue he went on to
a Justice League International story
where he hijacked the brain of Maxwell
Lord and it became more of a symbiosis
of person and technology which seems
more like what the TV show is doing but
I think the TV show explanation is is
that he became a metahuman during the
particle accelerator explosion
and that's when he gained his techno
path powers I think that's the ideas
that he's a techno path he controls
technology so like they're investigating
that crash at the beginning of the
episode where he shakes the elevator so
hard that it kills that person there's
even an Easter Egg for more recent flash
story from the negative flash that's
happening right now in the comics where
iris is like there you can't run down
that road they're doing construction the
flash has the negative Speed Force in
the comics right now so the whole thing
is is that he doesn't fully understand
how that's different from the normal
speed force so every time he runs the
negative Speed Force trashes the terrain
around him so he actually damages the
city when he runs without realizing it
so part of the idea with flash this
season is that he comes out of the Speed
Force like four times faster than when
he went in so because Barry's brain like
he says oh my brains all fine is back to
normal he doesn't fully understand his
abilities yet so he's probably gonna
break some stuff just because he's so
happy and excited to be back and he's
like a bull in the china shop but the
really cool is regulated on this
heads-up display for the suit is the
babble protocol as in the Tower of Babel
it's basically a protocol that Batman
develops in case the Justice League ever
goes out of control or turns evil he
needs to have a way to take each of them
down in Batman's special solution for
defeating the flash is the special
bullet that vibrates it's super speed
and stops him dead in his tracks
so there are a couple protocols in the
suit that we've seen in the other
trailers where it basically locks him
out like Barry gets locked out of his
own suit and can't take it off so that's
probably something to do with their
version of the Tower of Babel protocol
but like they say they're having a
little bit more fun so in the therapy
session they basically make fun of
themselves for all the crazy stuff and
the people that have died the last
couple of seasons my mom died
oh yeah my dad died too I had to go to
therapy as a child
the therapist says don't worry no one's
judging you in here which is sort of a
meta reference for the fandom all of the
fans are judging them and then iris says
Eddie you know I was engaged to him he's
dead too
thing about them growing up together
like brother and sister that all the
fans made fun of in the first two
seasons like isn't it almost like he's
marrying his sister because of the way
they grew up Ronnie died she mentions HR
who died for her at the end of season 3
iris says my mom
Laurel talking about arrow so subtle
arrow crossover
yeah we've been to a few funerals so
when you watch the episode see if you
can spot all of the references they have
to previous episodes when they're
talking in therapy I don't know if this
is gonna be the only time they do a
therapy scene they might have one in a
future episode but if they're gonna be
married during the mid-season finale I
don't think there's gonna be any therapy
after that so if they don't go back a
lot during the next couple of episodes
then this will probably be it but I
don't know for sure what will happen is
is I'll post my episode 2 video after it
airs tonight I also have some brand new
Titans and Nightwing season 1 to post so
that will probably wind up posting on
Wednesday congratulations to Pamela
Johnson you're the latest giveaway
winner please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here to
learn all about the Bart Allen reverse
flash Easter a during episode 1 and you
can click here to rewatch that Black
Panther trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight